and those numbers are spectacular one of
the best pitchers in the national league
uh mr strowman coming off that a little
tightness where he took himself out in
the first inning his fourth start
against the phillies all three of his
other starts were in
april he's two and one with an era of
.53 against the fighting phils
one for 11 in this series
and he smacks one to right field
overcomes conforto makes the dive and he
makes the catch
what a way to start the afternoon
michael conforto laying out to take a
basement away from herrera
lost the game two to one that's drilled
toward left center field cutting across
his pillar he dies and he makes the
catch
back to back
conforto and pillar laying out for the
first two outs
and alonzo
happy to see that one two coming to
jankowski and he got him
fastball on the inside corner and
strowman
puts down the first inning with some
help from his outfield
and now they get their third practice
here at zach wheeler yes zach as i said
uh coming off his worst start ninth in
earned run average
tied for second with his old buddy
degrom and strikeouts
mcneil sends one of the air to left
center field oh double got a really good
jump on it and immediately called off
mccutcheon
floated behind third base bowm going out
he's not going to get there and it lands
and it bounces into the stands for a
ground roll double
so lindor gets a little pop fly just
inside the chalk and he gets two bases
out of it
and he hits one on the ground past
hoskins in the right field of base in
mongol will be held at third as
jankowski gets it in quickly
an opposite field single for alonso and
the mets have runners at first and third
with one man out and michael conforto
coming up he kicks in the pitch
swung on a little looper over towards
third bone backs up makes the catch the
o2 pitch coming
ground ball left side boom's got it and
across the diamond in time
he's throwing it 14 of the time and he
strikes out
bowm with a high cutter
and he bumps it up the third base line
that's a good punt strowman took a look
over third and the ball is dropped at
first base by mcneil oh double herrera
bats with the base is full one out
and that one trickles behind mccann and
halfway down the line is maitan and now
he's in a rundown and he's tagged out by
dna
rookie mistake by nick mayton and that's
the second out of the unit
buildings are challenging the call
a great effort on the slide but
we never got him he did get back
how about it
all right
overturn and a good catch in the
phillies replay room
2-2 again and a swing and a drive to
right field conforto going back he'll
get there he reaches and makes the catch
two runners are going to tag and move up
and this will give the phillies the lead
as maitan will score on the sacrifice
fly by o'double herrera his 20th run bat
at in this season it's one to nothing
phillies
swinging a miss that ball had some
really good cut on it 95.
swinging a miss he threw it once might
as well throw it again two outs two
strikeouts for wheeler
groud ball over to first hoskins
has it
applies the tag have an inning yeah
and he bunts toward the left side
strowman's got it
wow and over to first in time and that
puts two in scoring position with one
out with alec balm coming up
that one's pulled out to shortstop
lindor makes the play run will score
it'll be an rbi for balm
and it's two nothing phillies
ball scorch and it was with the ball and
play good things happen
brings up nick maton with a runner at
second two down
that one's looped out to left that's
going to drop in for a base hit hoskins
around third he'll score mayton on his
way to second base and he'll get there
sliding an rbi double three-nothing
phillies
three-nothing phillies here's tires
three and one here's the pitch
swinging a dribbler towards third
charging in guillermo bare hand pick
throws on the run to first and it is not
in time and it gets by alonzo at first
another run will come home and tereya's
heads for second it's four to nothing
phillies so done just put the ball in
play good things can happen
but until you really start to anticipate
throughout the course of the game that's
filthy three strikeouts for wheeler
on the outside quarter 99 miles an hour
that is just absolute paint
swing and a miss at a high heater
five strikeouts two in a row here's
guillermo who grounded out his first
time up mckinney at second pillar at
first with nobody out
opposite way caught by balm so this is a
big at bat for mcneil two outs two in
scoring position he can change the
entire nature of this game with the base
hit
the o1 coming
off the hands out towards shallow center
herrera is there makes the catch
3-2 pitch swing gonna miss
swing and a miss he got him he finally
got him to swing over top of the cutter
seven strikeouts for wheeler
ground ball over to third
and bowm has it
and across the diamond in time the
inning is over
he's going
strikeout the cans throw and the tag
safe that's got his foot in
right there
that's pretty close mets are challenging
the call he might be out it's a quick
decision
and they call him out
[Applause]
and boom goes down swinging and corey
oswell finishes off four
shutout innings in relief zach wheeler
has done the rest scattering four hits
and keeping the mets off the board
through six innings his first pitch to
billy mckinney is swung on grounded
right side two hops hoskins has it on a
backhand flips underhand to first and
there's one pitch and one out to start
this seventh inning
check swing by pilar did he go yes he
did eight strikeouts
wheeler's ready to go the pitch
a little floater out toward third caught
by alec balm and the inning is over he's
had a lot of those today little soft
shots
to his infielders seven shutout innings
for zach wheeler
now alonso who has two of the mets five
hits and now the 2-1 pitch
swing on the ground ball the other way
base hit going into right center here
comes lendore around third he'll score
easily pete alonso again to the opposite
field philly's lead is cut to four to
one one out of nobody on and here's
pillar
and he rockets one to deep left field
forget that that is way out of here
kevin pillar homers for the second
straight day his eighth home run of the
year to get the mets within two the
minutes are down to their last out and
they'll send up left hand hitting
patrick mazeka
[Applause]
ground ball right side natan he's there
throws to first in time to get mazika
the ball game is over the phillies hang
on and win it four to two they split the
four game series two and two